&gt;&gt; What advice to you have for students
that are taking this course that are starting to learn about parallel computing?
So what can you say to them that they should be thinking about
as they grow and mature in this area?
&gt;&gt; Well first off, they've picked a good course,
because this is definitely an enabling technology.
By having experience and expertise in GPU computing
can let them be a vehicle for extracting,
you know, that kind of flops are free,
computation and unlock some of the things that researchers or industry
or even commercial space haven't been able to do yet,
because they just don't have the bandwidth, they don't have the compute power, horsepower.
Cuda NGB/g computing, in some cases, is meant to inspire.
I mean, just think about if computing was free.
If you didn't have to worry about, you know,
the flops or the bits per second.
What could you do with the kinds of problems in your space or in your field?
Being part of that revolution is totally fine,
and I see it everyday when I work customers
and selling GPUs or talking to developers.
I think they should be, not only just learning the technology
but thinking about what they could do with it and where they could apply it.
>> Thanks so much for spending some time with us today. I appreciate it.
>> Sure. Thanks John.